this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you for coming here too
the vegetable germplasm conservation and
research at the plant genetic resources
in Geneva New York
I'm the vegetable curator for the plant
genetic resources unit at the USDA ARS
the USDA is a plan AR s national plant
germplasm system includes germ plasm
repositories across the country all the
way holman to Miami and Geneva to
Riverside and also we have at Hilo and
Hawaii
these include the original plant
introduction stations various clonal
repositories and crop specific
collections and also some genetic stock
collections the national plant germplasm
system is a national network of people
and organizations conserving plant
genetic diversity it includes both
federal state and private organizations
the coordination is by the USDA ARS
while most of the funding is federal
funding there is also funding from state
and private organizations for example
the project at Geneva has funding from
Cornell through the Northeast nine
project and I also have different
companies see companies I worked with
like noonim out in Oregon who helped
with regeneration zuv onions the major
objectives of the national plant
germplasm system which is the same for
all the different planet reduction
stations colonal repositories etc is to
acquire germ plasm to preserve the
genetic diversity that we have to
document and catalog this
both passport and characterization and
evaluation data to evaluate this germ
plasm and most importantly distribute
the germ plasm the germ plasm
collections are not museum collections
but they're living collections which are
used we have two sites that are national
in scope the National genetic resources
laboratory operates the genetic
resources information network this has
all the data available from collection
environmental data word material was
collected past characterization and
valuation data and this is available
anywhere in the world through the
internet we are releasing shortly
beginning October 1st a new version of
this database which is easier for users
to access where they can actually
download large quantities of data
through Excel sheets the other major
activity of this laboratory is the plant
exchange office they make all the handle
all the issues for germ plasm exchange
internationally both germ plasm coming
in the US and Germany eaving the u.s.
they also arrange for collection
missions because now with the National
Rights for germ plasm has come up and
Convention on Biological Diversity
there's many issues of getting
permissions and handling benefit sharing
for germ plasm the other activity of the
National genetic resources laboratory is
also very important as the crop germ
plasm committees these are groups of
users and other researchers who meet
with the curators of various crops to
set issues for example what should be
characterized what should be brought
into the collection and deal with issues
such as duplicates in developing
vulnerability statements
we also have the national seed storage
laboratory in fort collins colorado it's
a part of a larger national center for
genetic resources preservation but they
maintain base collections of all the
germ plasm across the country in fort
collins at minus 20
as far as seed they also do research on
new techniques for preserving germ plasm
especially with the clonal repositories
right now the major clonal collection
that's preserved is the apple collection
they're trying with using dormant buds
and liquid nitrogen vapor they're trying
to develop techniques for other clonal
crops that would be as successful as
this technique is with apple and they
also maintains
Voucher samples such as the pvp samples
and also some black box collections
where we're just maintaining them as
black boxes with no access about the
plant genetic resources unit the
national research and marketing act of
1946 to authorize for regional plan
introduction stations geneva is one of
these the others are at Pullman
Washington Ames Iowa and Griffin Georgia
in July 1948 their Northeast Regional
project ne9 was started this was
developed into the north sent north
Eastern Regional Plan introduction
station also in 1984 the apple
repository was established as a part of
the PGR you it had been established
several years earlier by Cornell
University and was transferred to the
plant genetic resources unit as a
federal collection and this the two of
them were merged in 1988 to form the
plant genetic resources unit so in
nineteen and
since 1984 we've added coats Hardy
grapes and tart cherries to the clonal
repository our objectives are to
conserve and regenerate plant genetic
resources accessions in the gene bank
and in the field as far as the clonal
repositories to ensure its long-term
availability for research and crop
improvement we are working to
strategically expand the genetic
diversity in the collection but also to
expand the information both passport and
characterization data that we have for
these collections we're working to both
genetic do genotypic and phenotypic
characterization and evaluation of this
germ plasm to increase the utilization
efficiency we've started recently both
vegetable and fruit germ plasm working
on quality nutritional traits and traits
that have a health benefitting effects
but our major as with the whole [ __ ] germ
plasm system major objective is to
distribute this germ plasm both
nationally and internationally
this shows the vegetable genetic
resource is conserved at Geneva New York
as you can see we have a total of about
12,000 580 half of this collection is
tomato we have both cultivated and wild
this 6600 includes about 600 accessions
of wild tomato our other major
collections are coal crops or things
such as cabbage cauliflower broccoli etc
and onion but we do have large
collections of squash and radish and
smaller collections of tomatillo or Huss
tomatoes celery etc most of a large part
of the tomato collections backed up over
all 71 percent of our journey
plasm is backed up and this is like I
mentioned before at Fort Collins
Colorado our vegetable collections are
basically seed propagated collections
most of our crops except tomato are
cross pollinated mini or biannual and
again except for tomato what we actually
use to produce seed is not the product
so it's unlike other crops like
agronomic crops we have the problem that
it's not the product that's used for the
seed production our germ plasm AK
acquisition is some germ plasm
collection missions but more and more
recently has been from other germ plasm
collections and some breeding programs
both public and private
but our acquisition is more targeted now
specific regions for specific crops or
specific traits are certain types of
collection like we have introgression
populations for tomato that we acquired
them Israel that are available and our
collections are germ plasm acquisition
is user directed
again one of the major ways we do this
is through those crop germ plasm
committees they meet an average of every
year to year and a half at various other
meetings we'll have this meeting also we
look at the pattern of seed requests we
see what kinds of crops are being
requested but what type of traits are
being requested and this is what we're
using to direct our acquisition efforts
just wanted to show here is the US and
this is origins for various vegetable
crops
you can see that this shows the
importance of the germplasm collections
that we do have in the US and one thing
you'd need to point out especially in
this area and some of these areas it's
very difficult to obtain access to
collect germplasm or to get germplasm
back to the US some other germplasm
collections it's very difficult to
access this germplasm now with the
Convention on Biological Diversity so
this stresses the importance of what we
have and maintaining it this we did have
a collection since I've been here in
Mexico you can see some of the genetic
diversity here with tomatoes tomatillo
and some beans our collection this is a
cultivated crop I had previously been
involved in about 35 collections when I
worked at a Carta working with food
legumes but the principle is the same
oftentimes you go with cultivated crops
to the field as they're being harvested
to collect so you know where the region
is but sometimes you go to local markets
which are higher probability that the
crop that's being sold is from that
region so if you go to a local market in
Mexico like Puebla you're probably
getting your crop it was grown real
locally but if you go to the Mexico City
if you go there to a market that that
crop could have come from anywhere in
the country just an example here with
tomato how germ plasm the tomato
originated in Brazil I mean in the Andes
area it went to South American in the
1500s to Europe the original tomato germ
plasm in the US came from Europe not
from the
Center of origin or where the crop was
domesticated and then in 1930s USDA
collectors and then later cm Rick at the
tomato genetic Resources Center brought
a lot of wild species germ plasm into
the US and this has been integrated into
the populations for various traits such
as disease resistance and other pest
resistance again some of the geographic
origins of Brassica here where you see
the leafy vegetable effets ones cabbage
down in italy broccoli and cauliflower
and some indications of early
domestication in the mediterranean
region eastern part of it here is an
example of a very difficult to
accomplish but we've done it germ plasm
exchange was shining recently we
received actually just about one month
ago eighty-four accessions of chinese
cabbage radish and buckwheat from china
this is our first official exchange
since the early 1930s with china for
germ plasm and this is a direct result
we had sent broccoli and cauliflower to
china in 2012 and they were very excited
with it and they led to them inviting
myself in the research leader dr. Zhang
to visit them at their expense in
September last year about this time of
year we had many discussions there with
the head of germ plasm exchange at the
CA yes about bilateral germ plasm
exchanges and we've also recently sent
germ plasm of radish in the tomato core
collection to china and in about ten
days we expect to have the vegetable
curators and the institute of vegetables
and flowers and bed
visiting us in Geneva New York and they
want to discuss further bilateral
exchanges of germ plasm the discussions
are also going on for the fruit germ
plasm but we've already brought in
vegetable germ plasm this is myself and
dr. song we are here with the head of
testing laboratory testing at the
Chinese national gene Bank in Beijing we
also went to Han Xu this is the they're
growing out here as you can see this is
the broccoli and cauliflower we sent
them they were very anxious that we go
down and visit that and they're asking
us to come back in the spring of next
year because they hope to have this in
the breeding program full-blown in their
breeding program it's about two or three
hundred kilometres from the Han Xu in
the same province this is close to Hong
Kong so we've collected we're increasing
in the exchange of germ plasm the lady
here in the red blouse her name is dr.
mia Tao
she's very instrumental in getting the
germ plasm that we did in the US and
we're working out protocols with her
that once germ plasm is brought in to
China once that they're going to be
maintaining it and when I receive a
request for the same accessions I will
transmit it to her and then they will do
they won't have to go through quarantine
they will just distribute it than the
Chinese national gene bank and they were
very open to this type of distributions
and so she said that if they get a
request for what they were sent to me
from the US they will do the same so
we're hoping to expand this germ plasm
exchange to other vegetables what
several concerns we've had with our
collections are GMOs
they're difficult to put in the
collections because first of all it's
not one patent there's a series of
patents and it's very difficult we don't
want to keep track of all the different
patents and what's still in place
because it only takes one patent to make
it non distributable the other even more
important is the concern about
contamination of GMO and non-gmo
accessions to the point that we had an
inspection in the Office of Inspector
General visit we had inspectors come to
us several times and go through all our
list of accessions and actually go
through the gene bank itself looking to
make sure that we didn't have GMOs the
other concern we have is problems with
IP re issues because these affect what
will go into collections the mta's and
they may reduce to less germ plasm
entering intellectual property rights
and I'll give you a small example of
this darth dr. martha mutlar has double
haploid onions she was done with him she
really thought they should be available
for other people to use and we accepted
to put them in the collections but then
Cornell's IP our office got involved and
we had a lot of negotiations but the MTA
they wanted was too much for us to be
able to follow up we don't have the
resources to do that and so I was told
by the National leader program leader
that we could not accept this type of
MTA so the germ plasm we have our finite
resources and staff so we cannot put it
into something that we can't really
freely distribute and this is going to
happen more in the future even though
she really would like to see it
distributed and be a part of the
collection because of that in
I was not a type of MTA we could deal
with it's not going in again these mta's
affect our freedom of distribution the
Convention on Biological Diversity is
affecting collection missions and
getting permissions the plan exchange
office I mentioned has a lot more work
nowadays for germplasm collections we're
worried about uncontrolled uncontrolled
growth of the collections we have a
finite resource for storage for
regeneration for characterization we're
trying to avoid duplication both
regionally locally not internationally
but because of the problems it's
becoming more and more difficult to
distribute germplasm internationally
because of you know like property rights
also be I didn't mention before
quarantine is becoming so restrictive in
some countries that it makes sense to
have duplication so that you don't have
to go through this quarantine because
there in some countries like Australia I
worked with when I was Eddie Carter they
gave me a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year to work with fava-bean
germ plasm to screen it for disease
resistance because it cost them about
eight hundred dollars an accession to
bring it in so it was cheaper to pay us
to to go through the whole collection
and get the score so they only brought
in what was needed and they provided
pathologists to help
so quarantine issues are becoming very
important for germ plasm distribution
also our crops are stored in Geneva at
minus twenty so we maintain our
collection at minus twenty which helps a
lot in maintaining the viability it's
also backed up at minus 20 in Fort
Collins
our crops less I said before or mostly
cross pollinated and many are by annuals
so we use cages and we have beehives for
pollination this shows here a cage the
cages we use this is in Brassica here
behinds we use the cages with written we
just use rented hives because the
economics worked out much better for us
we do do some hand pollination when we
have squash with small numbers of plants
it's easy to do it with hand pollination
just an example this is some broccoli
and tomato some this year this broccoli
here actually is one that we're working
with Thomas Portman this is actually his
his population he's working with with
this scri grant again Brassica we we
plant cabbage about the beginning of
August
then in November dig it up store it and
then in early fall set it out for seed
production again with some of the
vegetable leafy type brassicas we will
have to actually take him to the
greenhouse our poly house after the have
been grown in the field because we can't
store them over winter another issue
short day onions here's what short day
onions look like grown versus long day
onions in Geneva New York you can't get
them to really bulb and if you brought
bulbs in here they wouldn't flower
because of the need for short days so we
have an agreement with New Mexico State
University and provide them funds to
assist us in regeneration of the short
days the main concerns we are concerned
with with
regeneration is loss of genetic
diversity and loss of genetic identity
we're also concerned about producing
disease-free seed and also our Brassica
and Allium is one of the main reasons we
went to minus 20 because their shelf
life is much less than say squash our
tomato our major another major activity
is characterization of germ plasm this
field is in Charleston South Carolina
well we we work with breeders a lot with
collaborate in collaboration for
characterization I've worked many
agreements with Philip Griffiths looking
at radish broccoli and cauliflower for
example we have a minimal descriptor
list we use for these crops highly
heritable traits and we're working to
increase the efficiency of utilization
of the germ plasm and increasing we have
an increasing importance of quality in
the past five years again
see we have this minimal descriptors
lists have been developed on the advice
of the CG C's we're working with and
we've implemented this as part of our
characterization what are the thing as
part of our regeneration and also
regularly now we take digital images
that was a strong recommendation through
Moll 5 C GCSE I had again we do
molecular and quality evaluation this is
a type of image that we take for onion
bulbs this is what was strongly
requested by the Allium CDC again a
different type of image done with tomato
this one just happens to be one of the
stuffing Tomatoes we have some of them
look like a red pepper bell pepper when
you see them in the field and people are
surprised
when I cut them open that they see
tomato the quality characterization has
become more and more important
we have already put quality as part of
our characterization within our
regeneration process for tomato I show
you later
tomato core collection and we've worked
on multi-year multi-site evaluation of
quality for the tomato core collection
with a number of collaborators and we
hope we starting now our next five-year
project plan and we're hoping to expand
this to crops such as onion and squash
just the nutritional characterization
with a standard preparation of samples
which are stored at minus 20 for later
evaluation for we have an automatic Thai
trader here for titratable acidity color
am eager for the lycopene we measure
vitamin C with the kit we also have
worked with the chemist at the ARS in
Albany California for his samples with
secondary metabolites instead of this
they're doing the prep of the sample on
liquid nitrogen in liquid nitrogen at a
cryo station our core set as I mentioned
I won't go over each one but they're
basically different landraces
heirlooms a group based on the geo
diversity fruit shape and then we have
50 we call obsolete varieties these are
where we could we tried to trace them
down to the 40s 50s 60s 70s and 80s and
90s where we had PvP certificates or
information other information that
they're released in these decades
again we we have something from Ohio
State
tomato analyzer to look at the various
morphological traits of tomato it
measures a number of traits this is with
heirlooms several quality traits and we
found two lines Fon Zilla and this one
is something called AVR d6 which stood
out for a several of the traits compared
to the other accessions and the same
there were duplications geo diversity
landrace heirloom they don't add up to
one hundred and eighty four because some
are in several groups and this a VAR d
six was in another group with the geo
diversity you can see it it's high for
all three traits and then again that we
found significant genotype effects for
these quality traits one thing that we
did was look at the different decades
accessions them the 50 60 70 s 80s and
90s we did find a fairly strong with
bricks a trend of reduced bricks from
the 50s through the 90s and some type of
indication for vitamin c very small
indication with titratable acidity so
there has been a reduction for sure and
bricks and vitamin C to some extent
we took the 10 we have more data for the
10th in the 1990s and what we did was
canonical discriminant analysis and what
we had here was two years that we grew
them so for the morphological traits
that the 10 gave exactly they were right
on top of each other for the
morphological traits the morphological
traits were very good at distinguishing
these varieties from each other and
while the quality you can see they're
not right on top of each other they were
fairly repeatable as far as the quality
traits for these 10 varieties we also
did a discriminant and what we were
looking at here was Bell's gourmet and
red bear stick out from the rest of them
and the reason they do this is for the
morphological was size traits they were
very different between the red pear and
the Belle's gourmet the bells gourmet
you get fruit that are like three pounds
it's really huge the red pear is a very
small tomato
whereas here with red pear and bells
gourmet looking with the quality traits
what we noticed the difference was the
different acids the red pear was double
the acid content of the bells gourmet we
were just trying to see which traits and
that's what showed up here for the
quality factor analysis the first factor
was traits the sugar the second factor
was these acid traits citric acid malic
acids titratable acidity
Johanne labate the molecular biologist
looked at these 50 populations that we
had for 18 snips and what she did was
divide them up differently she divided
them up into private breeding company
varieties and public varieties developed
by universities and basically there
wasn't much difference between the two
populations it was there wasn't much
difference whether it was public or
private they showed the same values in
the snips another work that we're
starting on a new project plan is the
GIS or geographical information system
and what we're looking at we there are a
set of species new species from the new
monograph on tomato' solanum peruviana
has been divided into four species
including peruviana Arcanum Cornell
Marie I and Julio sense and we were
trying to see the geographic
distribution of these species and also
to see how could we distinguish these
species with markers and she used some
snips from genotyping by sequencing I
had 14,000 43 snips and what she did was
took the red boxes this is distance
geographical distance and vertical axis
is genetic distance and what she did was
interest specific so that would be like
a Solanum peruviana medicine land
improvy annum accessions to accessions
of the same species whereas the blue
ones are two accessions of different
species like peruviana and Arcanum
so what you see here with the red ones
there further they are apart physically
there's not a relationship with the
genetic distance but you can see there
is a relationship of genetic distance
and geographic distance for the interest
specific pairs so this shows as this the
species get further apart they're more
distinct from each other and this is
shown when you try to taxonomic Leakey
these out which we took all 200 and did
we ran into problems and I think you can
see that if they're close to each other
in Geographic distance they become more
close in genetic distance and it becomes
more difficult
she looked at a minute with a heat map
basically some species are easy to tell
apart peruviana min Arcanum so here the
this is the frequency of one species
Arcanum and this is the frequency of the
allele in a peruviana so the darker this
is the number the greater the number of
alleles so you can see a pattern like
this so it's these two species are
separate or easily easily more easily
separated whereas peruviana
and Cornell Marie I which is what we saw
in the field is very difficult to tell
them apart you can see with the snips
that there's not this pattern which
would distinguish them from each other
as far as allele frequencies again she
used this the same data here's our
Khanum fairly easy to separate it from
the rest and then the rest of them are
up here except Hulya since we had a
number of these that we could tell right
away but some that were more difficult
and that was these
so the species taxonomically that the
tax ottomans have made you run into
problems with certain ones and it's
probably because of gene flow between
the species actually telling them apart
again with characterization and
evaluation we're concerned about
importance and heritability of our
traits and reporting disease scores
consistently replication both in time
and environment also we have lack of
tomato we have multi-location multi-year
evaluations and comparisons and again as
I mentioned with not only at Geneva but
at other plant introduction stations and
repositories there's concern about
quality nutrition and health benefit
traits - we work with outreach and
training and germ plasm conservation and
regeneration with markers and seed
production and seed storage for
characterization and evaluation and we
do have outreach efforts in seed
production for organic production both
processing and actual control Paulo
Nations and we've worked with
demonstrations and field days we've had
three projects the public seed
initiative which was I fast funded and
the organic seed partnership and the
northern organic vegetable improvement
collaborative Novick
those have been funded by the OREA
the first two were with dr. Molly John
the Novick the last one has been with
dr. Michael Mazurek as a collaborator
the Novick again is a Cornell as part of
that Oregon State was University of
Wisconsin Washington State also an NGO
the organic seed Alliance and ourselves
and the USDA this northern organic
vegetable improvement collaborative is
working as you can see here we're
working with seed production seed
processing also we're looking at testing
of organic varieties on farmer's fields
under organic conditions so that they
can grow varieties which perform best
under their conditions and the breeding
programs have been working on
besides disease resistance also
extending the season like with sweet
corn making a developing sweet corn
which is more code tolerant at the
seedling stage there's at PG are you
working with some people with training
and seed cleaning we've this is public
seed initiative we were at a the organic
field day here at free ville two weeks
ago my staff and I were at organic field
day again in free ville we also go
regularly to the common fair grout
ground fair showing different aspects of
seed production and providing
information for different for producing
seed not only processing but pollination
control and so on
we'll be going there Thursday this week
again here is a student who had recently
graduated from RIT an adult student who
had finished recently and had further
training with us and two weeks ago she
was hired at a laboratory in rot
Chester finally the distribution of the
germ plasm is worldwide both to the US
and to the internationally 35 to 40
percent of all the samples I distribute
or out of the US so we do a large amount
of germ plasm distribution outside the
u.s we try to do it for breeders other
researchers where there's a valid use
for the germ plasm distribution we
distribute to nonprofit organizations
other institutes and universities just
the example a large amount of our germ
plasm is tomato as you can see here look
at these totals we start 2008 35 15 in
their last year fourteen thousand two
ninety and with sequestration and not
being able to fill positions this has
been very difficult dealing with these
distributions and there's not just small
distributions there have been we've
provided South Korea with whole
collections of our germ plasm like the
whole tomato the whole onion collection
for years yeah that was around three to
four thousand every year before 2008
well one thing was and we cut it out
some of it was these non-research
requests we were giving that to him and
saying we won't be able to give it to
you again but we've had a number like
noonim seed has asked for our whole
onion collection and hoe tomato
collection and I told them why do you
need it now they said we're worried
about excess in the future I said I just
can't do it you're good and so they
provided me
they came themselves and helped take the
seed under our supervision so they came
and actually did it
we've been repatriating germplasm to
places like south korea where they give
a list of stuff they think originally
came then they there have been companies
doing large-scale screenings like onion
for Irish yellow spot virus resistance
so these have what have increased our
distributions some of our problems is
the this germ plasm is distributed
freely but there are increasing numbers
of non research requests we don't
provide to farmers well we get a lot of
gardeners and private individuals saying
they're going to do research and what
we've done is basically telling them
where they can find seed that's more
appropriate to them we used to a lot of
the sites in the germ plasm system used
to say okay here's some of what you
asked for
please don't ask in the future these are
where you can go now we've taken a very
hard stand that if you're not if we're
if I don't consider it and valid use we
send a rejection letter
most people accept it some complain and
then of those probably one out of ten
who complain I'll relook at it and give
it to them other issues are our costs
for shipping and phytosanitary
certificates have really increased and
we've been requested to provide
certification is GMO genetically
modified as being free of that because
of national policy I cannot provide that
I cannot provide a letter that says we
certify this GMO free I cannot provide a
letter that says to the best of my
knowledge there should be it should be
genetic GMO free that's national policy
it's out of my hands and then
requirements of certification is disease
and virus free because of the way we
multiplying stuff every year we'll have
400 plots a year for seed I can't do
that we don't have the resources for
field inspections rogen and testing it's
just too much we ask them to get a
research exemption if they want that and
then again our intellectual property
rights is always an issue with
distribution so in summary we conserve
regenerate characterize evaluate
distribute germ plasm of our fruit and
vegetable crops the degradation of
environments were the Centers of origin
is making our collections more important
also the lack of access to these centers
of origin and centers of diversity are
making the collections more important
now this germ plasm is you needed to
maintain and improve crop tolerances and
resistances we keep getting more and
more crops we're asking for quality
traits not just tomato but they've
started asking for onions
Tan's for example quartz inton and we're
using the GPS the molecular biologist
and then GIS to our characterization and
evaluation I just like to us acknowledge
the staff and the plant genetic
resources unit Joanne labate is the
molecular biologists geneticists Bill
Garmin is our farm manager Jonathan
Spencer works with our bees and
characterization Paul kiss ly with the
greenhouse sherry tennis handles all the
database work and paperwork for seed
orders Nancy consolee works with us
recently she takes care of all the seed
orders and seed packaging and so on
Suzanne Scheffer in the green laboratory
and now field characterization Suzanne
Schweiker is a was a trainee that worked
a lot with the tomato characterization I
worked very much with Phillip Griffiths
with different characterization projects
and with Michael Mazurek not only with
Novick but also with characterization
and previously with Molly John Mark
Farnum is the ARS a Brassica breeder who
hasn't been involved in the
characterization and her breast Rexha
worked with us with the
secondary metabolites characterization
for tomato
Christopher Cramer is the onion breeder
short-day breeder at New Mexico State is
helped out tremendously with short day
onions regeneration
Jim Myers heads up the Novick project at
Oregon State the OLAP Anthea's worked
very much with us along with festive and
ER nap in the tomato core collection
quality characterization so thank you
very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu